Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P.
I'm going to play a voicemail for you from a
caller who was very agitated, but this doesn't
seem to be a right winger attacking me, although
they are attacking me, but not from a right wing
perspective. This is someone who apparently
expects a Trump dictatorship and is worried
that I'm going to press the F you button on them,
which I don't know what that is. Maybe it means
that we have to bleep voicemails. I'm not sure.
Speaker 5: So do you push the F you button on
me because I was on a rant? You know, you're
making money on this, too. You love talking about
this. This is a this is disgusting. What's on You
realize nothing's going to happen. This guy so hit
the f you, but you can't do it. Who cares? Look,
we are going to be under dictatorship by Donald
Trump and his disgusting skank whole daughter in
this song. Oof! You watch and see what happens.
Goodbye before you hit the official button.
Speaker 1: Well, if there's no F-bombs,
there's no reason to hit the F-you button, which I
don't have. The F-you button is like that bleeping
stuff. So, listen, this guy's pessimistic. I get
it. I get I you know, the whole skank whole thing
as a way to reference to Ivanka. I'm not big
on that. But I sympathize with the sentiment
that nothing's going to happen. And, you know,
supposedly Trump's arrest was today. And I kept
saying, this is what Trump claims. We don't know
that that's the case. It doesn't seem as though
that's happening, although maybe by the time we
publish this episode, Trump will have been cuffed
and booked. But I doubt it. I sympathize with
this feeling that nothing is going to be done.
Trump won't be held accountable, and he will end
up back in power with his authoritarian delusions
and dreams. I hope that that isn't the case, but I
sympathize with the frustration. On today's bonus
show, we will talk about President Joe Biden
issuing his first veto. What was the veto over
and what are the implications? We will discuss it.
Secondly, Paris is increasingly under the weight
of stinky trash. Uncollected trash has mounted
to 10,000 tons because of strikes that are going
on. And as a result, I am canceling my trip to
Paris scheduled for two weeks from now. No, I had
a tentative visit to Paris when I'm going to be
in Europe in a few weeks, but for other reasons,
it's not happening. It has nothing to do with the
trash. And thirdly, North Carolina is urging the
Supreme Court to throw out a major elections case.
This is a case we've talked about before. This is
a case our bonus show audience will be familiar
with. And it is a very consequential case. We
will talk about why North Carolina is saying
to the Supreme Court, throw it in the trash,
flush it down the toilet 10 to 15 times. All of
those stories and more will be discussed today
when producer Pat joins me on the bonus show. We
do a bonus show every single day, every weekday,
every day that there's a show. If you want
access to the bonus show, simply sign up at
join Packman dot com and if you would like access
but. The financial commitment is too much for you
at this time. You can request a free membership
at the following URL David Pakman dot com slash
free membership. Don't email me about it. Sign up
to get a free membership at David Pakman dot com
slash free membership. I'll see you on the bonus
show. Otherwise, we'll be back here tomorrow.